this video is sponsored by enlisted when
I was a university student I worked at
an office part-time it was near the
Budapest railway station a major public
transit Hub of 12 Suburban Airlines in
metro line seven tram lines and multiple
bus lines and the whole area was just a
five minute walk away from silica man
Square which is an even larger Transit
Hub it is safe to say that the area I
worked at is one of the most well
connected places by public transit on
the whole planet at that workplace of
mine one of my colleagues a middle-aged
woman came in late every day by about 10
to 15 minutes after a few weeks I made
the terrible mistake of asking her how
she gets to work upon me asking she
responded I took the tram oh I said so
you commute by tram every day no she
said I go by car but didn't you just say
that you take a tram tour oh yeah but I
usually can't find a parking space
nearby so I drive far away down to the
lower streets find a free spot there and
then take the tram for two to three
stops back to the office
on top of this when asked where she
commuted from she said she lived next to
a metro station at that point I had to
excuse myself for fear of having a
stroke should the conversation continue
this person had access to world-class
public transportation in one of the most
reachable areas on the planet and yet
she took the car every day and the worst
thing was as I found out that colleague
wasn't the only one who did this
practically half the office was doing
the exact same thing every day and then
complained about traffic and the lack of
parking spaces most people would
attribute this Behavior to laziness or
stupidity or both and that very well
might be the case however there is
another reason for such Behavior his
systemic one see every street around the
office and the nearby streets had free
parking for most people both in America
and Europe being able to leave your car
basically anywhere for free is as
natural as having access to electricity
or running water free parking is just a
thing that exists a basic factor of life
and if anyone wants to take it away Lord
help them in the end sewing public
backlash
but the thing is usually there is no
such thing as a quote-unquote free
service in most cases if you're not
paying for something that means someone
else paid for you it's called a subsidy
now not all subsidies are a bad thing
State subsidized Healthcare education
and public transportation are the
foundations of modern civilization and
they produce vastly better outcomes than
a purely free market system but when it
comes to subsidized quote-unquote free
parking the success story quickly turns
into an unmitigated financial disaster
and the money is just one of the severe
problems why is free subsidized parking
such a bad idea let me explain and this
is the point where proponents of car
traffic usually start talking about the
war on cars whatever that would be there
is no war on cars but if there was I'm
sure I would be enlisted how's that very
Segway thanks to enlisted for sponsoring
today's video enlisted is a multiplayer
FPS set in World War II with a heavy
focus on historical authenticity while
also keeping the gameplay fun and
engaging a neat game mechanic is squads
mode where you control your own team of
soldiers give them orders and equip them
before the battle then during battle you
can freely take control of any of them
if you die no matter you can just switch
to another soldier with respawn
happening if your whole Squad gets wiped
out I like how many options this game
gives you for your exact play style
whether infantry mechanized aerial and
so on Some people prefer assault rifles
other sniper rifles but my thing is high
caliber consequently I'm sorry D-Day has
been postponed and Lister is available
on PC Xbox and Playstation both the
current and previous generations and
with cross-platform support there is no
purchase necessary just register using
my link in the description and start
playing for free once you do you'll get
a free bonus of 3 days of Premium Time
and several orders both for troops and
weapons thanks for checking out our
listed they help me make more content
for you now back to the video so why is
free parking such a bad idea reason
number one
public and private spaces exist on land
and land is a finite resource especially
inside City Limits when a City Markets a
lot of land for development it has to
decide what will go there commercial
space office space residential units
makes these build things all too often
cities take such valuable Urban Land and
turn it into asphalt car storage instead
of workplaces shopping areas or much
needed housing land plots just get
turned into parking lots this also
happens on a micro level on your average
Urban Street you can have on-street
bicycle storage benches a line of trees
restaurant Terraces all things that make
the street more pleasant and increase
local real estate value but no instead
those spaces just get turned into free
parking lots despite the fact that in
the US on average each on-street parking
lot costs 1750 to build and 400 dollars
per year to maintain not only is this
inefficient space use but an
economically nonsensical one it's
subsidizing a few core users Lifestyles
with taxpayers money because your guess
is as good as mine not to mention
Parking Services create heat Islands
inside cities if we cut down all the
greenery to make space for more metal
boxes we shouldn't act surprised when
our cities become unbelievable during
the hot summer months to this some
people might respond with just get it AC
bro I guess an AC works fine for them
but not for me because I also go outside
sometimes on another issue I rarely hear
people talk about is the fact that
excessive free parking induces demand if
parking is easy and cheap more people
will choose the car and you'll need more
and more parking spaces if parking is
reasonably priced and we don't demolish
our city center to create an insane
amount of Supply less people will choose
the car and you'll need less parking
spaces this is a lesson even some
European cities haven't understood yet
the city of Prague recently inaugurated
a fully renovated Street where they gave
the sidewalk to cars because quote there
are not enough parking spaces it never
really occurred to them that building
more parking spaces will cause more
people to get in their cars thereby
needing even more parking spaces and the
Vicious Cycle is thus complete parking
in Prague is not free though but the
prices are so low fines are so laughable
and enforcement is so weak that it might
as well be free in Prague like many
other similar cities driving is
completely optional for 99 of people how
is it then fair to use taxpayers money
to subsidize the minority's preferred
way of Transit it's not fair at all but
it gets worse
when we turn an acre of land into an
acre of parking we create next to no
value even if we charge for entry the
revenue would barely cover maintenance
let alone construction costs also when
you see a giant half MTS fault lot
consider what else could have been built
there and office complex Apartments a
commercial center or a nice mixed-use
neighborhood that would all provide much
needed revenue for the city as an
asphalt desert it's nothing but a
financial black hole for you to shovel
more and more taxpayers money into with
three on-street parking the situation is
the same just on a smaller scale now a
common argument against instituting
working fees or decreasing the number of
spaces is that without ample free
parking businesses would go broke this
is false it just doesn't happen in fact
once the street is made nicer by the
addition of trees benches and other
amenities instead of a row of parked
cars baking on the asphalt the number of
customers actually increases in any
given City areas with less scores there
are more pedestrian friendly are some of
the most sought after places go figure
another aspect of free parking none
other people talk about is its effect on
real estate prices if a developer has to
build say two parking spaces per
apartment guess who's paying their
expense you the person buying the
apartment regardless whether you plan on
owning a car or not if the lot is in an
underground or above ground garage this
extra cost goes up even further by up to
thousands of dollars suddenly free
parking doesn't sound so enticing does
it but there is another aspect of free
parking that makes it an even more
terrible idea
[Music]
free parking induces demand and
incentivizes car Centric planning the
more cars there are the more planners
will plan around cars until you end up
with a city like Houston a place where
you absolutely need a car to get around
full stop needless to say putting the
entire city behind an auto industry
paywall is a bad idea affecting
low-income households the most think of
it this way the more hurdles and
paywalls poor people have to jump over
to escape poverty statistically the
viewer will succeed meaning more people
will stay poor poverty correlates with
crime so the more poor people that are
in an area the higher the crime rate
will be therefore it is in everyone's
best interest to help as many people as
possible Escape poverty with
core-centric Planning incentivized by
free parking this becomes a lot harder
to achieve most often the first step of
escaping poverty is getting a job but
you also have to get to your job and if
it can only be done by core you're now
stuck with having to pay the high cost
of car ownership and if you're climbing
up from Rock Bottom there is no real
guarantee that you'll be able to do it
so to sum up as we've discussed free
parking leads to a deficient space use
creates heat Islands swallows taxpayers
money the United City's income motivates
people to get in their cars increases
the price you pay for housing and thus
significant socioeconomic damage with
all that said what's the solution to
this problem the good news is there are
multiple both short and long term each
better than the previous a great Step
One is beginning to charge for parking
inside City Limits and if it's already
paid making it reasonably priced the
rule of thumb here is that parking
should be priced so that at any given
time only 80 percent of parking spaces
are occupied if it's more than that
parking is too cheap if it's less
parking is too expensive San Francisco
tested an automated system that records
parking space occupancy when it reached
a certain percentage the system
increased fees by 25 cents when
occupancy dropped below a certain value
the fee decreased by 25 cents just this
tiny change reduced the time people
spend looking for spots by 43 from 11
and a half minutes to six and a half the
city of Budapest is also a telling
example one of the districts had free
parking up until this year and the
parking situation was catastrophic with
practically no free spaces to go around
but instead of building more free
parking the district started charging
for it the result was that 1400 cars
simply disappeared from the streets as
their owner decided it's not worth
paying for parking passes instead of
spending Millions on parking garages the
district had to spend nothing for extra
parking capacity and even started making
money in the process so charging for
parking is step one the more
far-reaching solution is decreasing the
number of parking spaces in parallel
with establishing good alternatives to
driving people are inherently lazy if we
could we would even drive to the toilet
so does this mean we should knock out
the bathroom wall and put in a garage
door of course not because we recognize
that just because something would be
convenient that doesn't mean it's a good
idea in the same vein if you give people
the option to drive into the city they
will because it's fast and convenient
but if everyone does it you'll end up
with Houston just like outfitting your
toilet for private car traffic
outfitting your city center for Mass
public car traffic would be a stupid
idea I mean it was a stupid idea in many
cases just look at these photos Jesus
Christ we can decrease the number of
parking spaces by actually building
something useful on them to provide the
city with extra Revenue got the giant
asphalt desert somewhere redevelop it
into something useful like in your
neighborhood those parking lots aren't
full even on Black Friday so turning a
few Luts into apartments or something
really wouldn't hurt anyone or even if
your city is too far gone if there are
no alternatives to cars and you need
those giant Lots otherwise businesses
will go bankrupt fine just put up
buildings where you turn the ground
floor into parking and the building sort
of stands above it boom you got a new
neighborhood additional jobs housing and
tax revenue decreasing the number of
parking lots is also useful when it
comes to on-street parking provided
there is an alternative to cars doing
that will not cause a traffic apocalypse
because decreasing parking capacity also
decreases the number of unnecessary
trips that is if people had a reasonable
alternative like biking walking or
public transit but chose to drive anyway
for convenience because hey there's
plenty of parking anyway if spaces are
harder to come by more people will
choose Alternatives and the less parking
spaces you will need to begin with at
that point you can use the freed up
space for all sorts of amenities that
will increase the desirability and value
of the neighborhood and all we had to do
was get rid of a subsidy for a
privileged minority no more privileges
even they shall be sent to war reminder
click the link in the description and
start playing and list it for free
viewers of mine using my link will get a
free bonus of three days of Premium Time
and several orders for both troops and
weapons thank you for your kind
attention at the end of the day I want
to make things more fair when it comes
to urban planning and parking free
parking and the ensuing course Centric
areas are subsidized heavily by all
taxpayers not just via the construction
and maintenance of parking lots but also
through the missing revenue from not
having something productive there
instead if you don't own or use a car
you should not be forced to pay for
those who do unlike Healthcare education
or public transit freebies for cars
aren't a public good they are a
convenience in denser areas in luxury
even of course making things more fair
and equal on the parking front is an
uphill battle with many opponents on the
way after all to those who are
privileged a quality feels like
oppression but it's a battle we have to
wage to make our cities better and more
livable not just for drivers but also
for the silent majority thank you for
watching this was my video about free
parking and why it's not so free after
all and if you like my content I
encourage you to check out my patreon
and consider supporting me there and
I'll be seeing you next time
foreign
[Music]